personnel coming out of the church we
have armed personnel approaching for the
church request permission to engage
copy you are clear to engage the moving
vehicle and any person all around you
see affirmative
you are cleared to engage the church in
2007 call of duty changed leaving the
historical trappings of World War two
for the landscape of modern warfare
Activision shooter series became an even
bigger juggernaut setting new trends for
multiplayer progression across the genre
over the next decade its annual entries
wound through the Cold War near future
conflicts and far-flung sci-fi battles
but this year Call of Duty returns to
its World War two roots and after the
campaigning I just finished I'm not so
sure this homecoming was the best idea
this new entry Call of Duty goes back to
the past in too many ways if you're
watching this video there's a decent
chance you've seen World War 2 through
the lens of pop culture maybe you read
Art Spiegelman's Maus or saw Saving
Private Ryan 12 times or re-watch Band
of Brothers in the years since its HBO
debut and for good reason these are all
worthwhile stories with their own take
on one of history's most catastrophic
events 1 explore the generational divide
between Jews who survived the Holocaust
and their children the next depicts
battles with repulsive accuracy the last
examines the bond between soldiers and
the effects of war on a person's psyche
even the very recent Dunkirk showed us a
different kind of war film less about
fighting and more about survival boredom
and anxiety all of this is to say that
any new additions to the world war 2
Pantheon have a high bar to meet they
don't all have to say something profound
about it but at the very least they need
to earn their historical setting present
us with something worthwhile show us why
they couldn't tell their story in any
other place or a time call of duty world
war 2 s campaign completely fails to
meet this challenge on the rare
occasions sledgehammers campaign does do
something new or interesting it wavers
opting instead to tiptoe around
creativity reverting to dated gameplay
mechanics throughout its six hour
runtime there are at least 10 QuickTime
events & 5 turret defense sequences
several sections are on Rails and so
called heroic events don't feel heroic
at all they're choreographed to the
point of yanking me out of the game once
upon a time it was novel to cover your
squad from a sniper's perch it was
thrilling to clear a series of
machine-gun nests but after years of
performing these same tasks across
numerous genres it's gotten old they've
been done since and in many cases much
much better holding call duty to the
same standard as some of the best World
War two films books graphic novels and
television shows may seem unfair
especially considering that there are
superhuman abilities in multiplayer and
undead monsters in coop but this is a
franchise that has sold over a quarter
of a billion copies in lifetime sales it
is one of the most ubiquitous names in
videogames if I'm going to buy a new
entry every year I want my time and
money to be worth it and when the
developer behind the game openly admits
they're trying to make it feel authentic
I'm naturally going to expect more or at
the very least something different there
are a few moments when this newest game
borders on clever an espionage level is
one of my favorites and actually creates
a tension I have an experience in this
franchise before but that all washes
away when I realized it was a glorified
multiple-choice test with only two
possible answers to each question at
this point you might be thinking well
they can't rewrite history and solders
didn't go to battle during World War two
saying let's do something crazy that
will make a great game in 70 years and
you're right this isn't Wolfenstein or
The Saboteur developer sledgehammer
games has a very specific vision for
what they want this campaign to be but
now we're back to boots on the ground
make it feel like it's in the war yeah
not just outside the war or a part of
the war it is in the middle of it
strategic and fast-paced and grounded
but rooted in a cause that's really
remarkable everything has to be detailed
down to like you know the buttons on the
pockets and patches on the right side to
not only bring this to life and a fun
way for fans to make sure that the
storytelling
honors that conflict I have no problem
with this if you're going to set a game
during a real extremely bloody conflict
you're straddling a tough line between
being honest and making a fun game to
begin with
that's a tough challenge but
sledgehammer doesn't do much with its
authenticity its characters are all
stereotypes back home you want to settle
something you do it head-on it's the
only way to earn respect the main plot
revolves around a hard-headed sergeant
and a compassionate lieutenant who often
butt heads
it's a slew of cliches that explore the
tension between the mission and empathy
and once again it regurgitates scenes
we've seen in countless other games
welcome to the bloody first you're a
long way from Texas farm boy even last
year's infinite warfare asked more
compelling questions about the toll of
leadership and right when you think
World War two story might delve into
tough but compelling subjects such as
the experience of Nazi labor camps or
your relationship with a person of color
during the Battle of the Bulge it veers
away these moments seem to exist just so
sledgehammer can say look isn't this
true to the time period before moving on
to the next set piece
[Music]
Call of Duty World War two's campaign is
all the more disappointing when you
remember that the franchise rates
created specifically as a reaction to
Medal of Honor which became redundant
with each new entry and strayed from its
so-called authentic routes infinity
ward's Vince Zampella and Jason West at
the time wanted to return to what made
their earlier games great and with the
first Call of Duty in 2003 they
succeeded since then the series has
gradually slipped away from its
historical roots it let you battle
robots super soldiers and fictional
spies by doing so a series shrugged off
the weight of a dark historical period
in going back to the place where it all
started the team was assuming a huge
risk
but would call duty World War two
sledgehammer doesn't really earn its
setting during the Second Great War it's
a mishmash of movies and games we've
seen numerous times already and when it
does show potential it usually squanders
it no this game does not look like it
could have released in 2003 but it sure
feels like it
it's as if sledgehammer wanted to simply
make the best looking World War 2
experience and not the most compelling
if they were trying to make the next
great action blockbuster they fell we've
seen this all before
[Music]